[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana para hablar de las
posibles salidas a la Guerra de Ucrania
a partir de la visita del presidente
francés de macron a la casa blanca estos
días nos acompañan en este estudio
eusebio baal corresponsal de la
vanguardia bienvenido Hola qué tal Yago
del barrio es ingeniero energético de
seanspo en París bienvenido Yago Buenos
días Gracias
corresponsal del diario el periódico
bienvenido Buenos días gracias por la
mitad y en duples desde Moscú nuestro
corresponsal sabía con las Buenos días
Hola Hola Buenos días encantado de estar
aquí Ucrania hay luz al final del túnel
hoy nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
macron ha viajado a Estados Unidos en
visita de estado para verse con biden e
intentar resincronizar las agendas a
ambos lados del Atlántico por un lado la
receta de salida a la crisis en Europa
hay temores al proteccionismo
estadounidense a partir de la llamada
ley de reducción de la inflación que
prevé subvenciones masivas del lado
político hay síntomas de que las
posiciones se acercan desde la invasión
de rusa de Ucrania macron apoya aquí
pero manteniendo siempre ese hilo de
comunicación como Moscú para un eventual
mesa de negociaciones reticente
inicialmente Washington parecía
acercarse últimamente a esta postura
algo a lo que se resisten los ucranianos
en este punto de una guerra que está
siendo un verdadero quebradero de cabeza
para Vladimir Putin repasemos algunas
portadas diario lemond dedico esta
portada a la liberación de gersón gersón
liberada El júbilo de los ucranianos en
el país entrevista El presidente
ucraniano zelensky marcando condiciones
para la negociación con las anexiones
Putin anula cualquier posibilidad de
diálogo de economist imaginando La Paz
Ucrania con esta llamativa portada bueno
resincronizar parece que es la palabra
eusebio las agendas de macron y la de
biden ambos han subrayado su Alianza
frente a Putin Pero hay un acercamiento
a dejar una puerta abierta a la
negociación
bueno lo de resincronizar Yo creo que el
presidente francés siempre construye
intelectualmente muy bien su mensaje que
tiene mucho sentido Pero a la hora de la
verdad cuesta mucho de poner en práctica
No
esta resincronización
Estados Unidos Es evidente que es uno de
los que se benefician en la práctica de
la Guerra de Ucrania que ha sido un
seísmo geopolítico y económico Por qué
Pues porque tiene una industria
armamentística que puede exportar mucho
a los aliados
la lista de pedidos es enorme puede
exportar su gas licuado
objetivamente Está sacando ventaja de
esto que pueda ponerse de acuerdo en
moderar ese proteccionismo con Europa me
parece un poco complicado porque ya
Europa ella misma tiene problemas para
sincro entre los países no entre
Alemania y Francia entre los países más
próximos a Ucrania y los que no se
sienten tan amenazados y va a ser
difícil que
a los dos lados del Atlántico se tomen
medidas que que no perjudiquen ambas
partes Enrique resincronización de
agendas Sí bueno esta reunión se produjo
en un contexto de decisiones más o menos
crecientes no en Europa en Europa y
Estados Unidos no sobre todo respecto a
la cuestión de la protección del
proteccionismo y el malestar que ha
provocado no entre la clase política y
la clase empresarial la ley de inflación
de Estados Unidos no que amenaza con una
desindustrialización real de Europa del
viejo continente luego yo creo que
respecto a esta reunión no ha salido
ningún compromiso firme y será
importante observar que va a suceder la
semana que viene una reunión que tendrá
lugar el 5 de diciembre entre el consejo
de tecnología y comercio Europa y
Estados Unidos donde se tiende a
coordinar esas cuestiones a nivel
transatlántico habrá que ver si en este
consejo sobre Europa sus objetivos es
conseguir algunas derogaciones respecto
a esta ley de reducción de la inflación
en Estados Unidos de relaciones de
algunos sectores donde no se vean
afectados
pues las subvenciones muy importantes no
de hasta 369 mil millones de dólares lo
que va a destinar Estados Unidos para
criar actividades que el hecho y hay
empresas como el mismo grupo francés que
están diciendo que van a instalar
empresas en Estados Unidos o la española
iberdrola que ha renunciado a ciertas
inversiones en Europa para programas de
desarrollo en Estados Unidos sabía
ecolas Moscú las líneas rojas y los
objetivos del kremlin han ido moviéndose
en estos nueve meses de guerra La
retirada de gerson fue el punto de
inflexión Cuáles serían ahora los nuevos
objetivos de Putin
bueno es difícil saberlo puesto que el
mismo
ha causado bastante desconcierto con las
listas de objetivos que he ido apuntando
desde el principio recordemos desarmar
Ucrania desmitificar Ucrania que
hubiesen a retirada de los de las
fuerzas de la otan hacia las posiciones
del 97 los propios rusos están
desorientados pero lo que da la
sensación es que una vez que no se ha
conseguido esa invasión barata sencilla
rápida que pretendía el en un principio
ahora Estamos en una fase de desgaste en
el que toda en la que todas las
esperanzas del están puestas por ejemplo
en el invierno y que el invierno sea
demasiado duro para los ucranianos y
también para los europeos que empiezan a
presionar a sus gobiernos a que no
apoyen
con armas ya más a Ucrania y luego sobre
todo un desgaste del armamento que
Ucrania gaste armamento los ucranianos
se vean empujados a alcanzar algún tipo
de acuerdo con Rusia es decir ceder
parte de su territorio Y probablemente
también de su soberanía ante los
intereses de Moscú en resumen como como
no se logró la llamada Billy screen la
invasión Relámpago Pues ahora el kremlin
estaría reajustando y Apuesta por ese
desgaste de los ucranianos y europeos
con el invierno y encima las
consecuencias de la guerra son palpables
y aún pueden ser lo más Francia se
prepara para cortes de suministro este
invierno en el mes de enero con un
programa por departamentos con trenes
anulados infraestructuras protegidas
etcétera ya de qué va a depender que
lleguemos a este extremo como van a
funcionar esos cortes de suministro y la
información que se le va a dar al
ciudadano pues como comunicó el
presidente de El otro día va a depender
mucho del tiempo en función de mirar al
cielo para ver si nos van a cortar si
tenemos un invierno muy frío y no se
reactivan toda la flota nuclear que está
prevista reactivarse el sistema va a
entrar en tensión porque va a haber
puntos las horas pico por la mañana y
por la tarde donde puede haber más
necesidad de consumo que te suministro
entonces según ha reportado
edf y RT que es el operador del sistema
mediante un mediante una herramienta
llamada ecobat lo que van a es lo que
van a notificar al ciudadano es la
tensión que tiene el sistema para ver si
en las horas punta es necesario que
ciertos departamentos es decir las
ciertas regiones de departamentos que no
estén conectadas a infraestructura clave
como pueden ser hospitales
cuarteles gendarmería puedan sufrir
cortes de hasta dos horas en su
suministro eléctrico entonces Esto va a
depender muchísimo del frío y de las
suministro que hay por parte de la flota
nuclear Pero entonces la causa
fundamental de estos cortes llegaran es
el nuevo retraso en la puesta en marcha
de los reactores nucleares franceses y
no tanto está conectado con la coyuntura
de Ucrania claro al principio del año
del Invierno todo el mundo pensaba que
los posibles problemas de corte de
suministro vendían por falta de gas y
falta de potencia desde la parte del gas
de no poder suministrar suficiente
electricidad mediante centrales de ciclo
combinado pero el problema que tenemos
ahora real es que no hay suficiente
potencia nuclear porque hay mucha más
están muchas más paradas de lo que
estaba programado de momento no es por
el problema de Ucrania sino por la falta
de potencia nuclear Y a partir de ahí la
imagen el usuario que proyectaría un
país como Francia una potencia nuclear
si llegaran con cortes de suministro si
va a tener un coste político para este
gobierno y para el presidente macron sin
duda que un país del g7 de los más
industrializados se Halle en esa en esa
coyuntura pues lo va a pagar y va a ser
en un momento quizás crítico para macron
cuando está preparando la reforma de las
pensiones la gran reforma de su
presidencia que va a generar sin duda
mucha protesta en la calle se van a
sumar estos dos fenómenos de
posibles cortes de energía con todo con
toda la en fin las consecuencias que eso
va a tener y una una protesta un
malestar en la calle ante una reforma de
las pensiones no es un escenario muy
favorable para el presidente macron
quizá Enrique el gobierno francés
contemporizó algo la reforma de las
pensiones y no produzca un cóctelería
explosivo juntando los cortes de
suministro la coyuntura actual y la
reforma
sí es posible no tenemos a bola de
cristal para saber qué va a pasar no es
posible que contemporice pero al mismo
tiempo el riesgo de contemporizar es de
querer aplicar esta forma más tarde en
un momento donde la popularidad del
presidente francés aún puede ser más
débil no por las consecuencias de esos
cortes será totalmente la popularidad es
más alta de la que tuvo momentos
críticos de su primer mandato como los
charocos amarillos pero es relativamente
baja la popularidad y no es un momento
fácil aparte A eso se le suma de que en
este segundo mandato no tiene mayoría en
la asamblea nacional que hace que no que
no a menudo los no sean fáciles y pues
sí es un momento complicado y en el caso
de estos cortes de luz hay que recordar
que se producirían pocos meses después
de las imágenes que ya vimos en las
gasolineras que también se produjo por
otro problema que no tenía nada no tenía
nada que ver con la guerra en Ucrania si
fueran las huelgas muy importantes en
las refinerías pero que ya tienen una
imagen de Caos y una mala imagen de
Francia y que tuvieron también un coste
político interno para para macrón y su
gobierno Y a todo esto cuánto se puede
extender la Guerra de Ucrania sabía con
sus efectivos agotados una guerra que no
ha salido como pretendía y el malestar
de familiares de soldados hay síntomas
de que el kremlin pueda estar
persiguiendo una tregua para respirar o
para rearmarse independientemente de las
negociaciones hay síntomas de
desesperación es posible que exista algo
algo de eso porque
Moscú se ha encontrado con más problemas
de los que esperaba en esta invasión en
este avance sobre sobre Ucrania se ha
expresado varias veces la idea de que
algún alto podría convenir más a Rusia
que a Ucrania aunque solo sea porque
Rusia es un país que tiene un mayor
potencial mayor autonomía mayor
población y el paso del tiempo y una
pausa podría permitir reforzarse y
Volver a empezar desde el principio
lanzar un nuevo todos los
llamamientos por parte de Rusia a
negociar ahora mismo son una distracción
porque hay que tener a Ucrania desde
luego desde el punto de vista
humanitario Pero sí desde el punto de
vista médico y es difícil de imaginar
que ahora mismo de verdad conseguir algo
notable en una negociación ante un
Ucrania que Está avanzando y avanzando
creen que son ahora los ucranianos los
que tienen el peso para decidir cuándo
sentarse Esa mesa
eso lo que es el mensaje oficial que da
por ejemplo aquí el presidente macron
No creo que Ucrania vaya a frenar en
este momento y negociar con Putin
sinceramente lo veo muy difícil
se produjera un cambio en el kremlin con
a otra persona al frente aunque fuera
del entorno de Putin las cosas
cambiarían sería psicológica y
políticamente más fácil para selensky
vender esa negociación pero con Putin
después de todo lo que ha ocurrido
después de los crímenes de guerra de esa
brutalidad
que se muestre sobre el terreno no veo
ahora mismo
posibilidad de una negociación coincide
Enrique
es muy complicado negociar con Putin lo
cierto que entre los dirigentes
franceses alemanes pero también
estadounidenses hay cada vez más la
convicción que tiene más peso que esta
guerra no puede durar Eternamente no
porque también hay el sentimiento un
poco de que esta guerra en el fondo un
poco la está ganando nadie planea Ha
logrado contraatacar Ha logrado
recuperar está en una mejor quizás una
mejor posición para negociar que en
marzo y abril pero una contundente
Ucrania tampoco no está nada Claro que
pase eso no no hay indicios de que el
ejército ruso se vaya a desmoronar
hacemos una breve pausa en este punto y
enseguida volvemos para seguir hablando
de este asunto aquí en Primera Plana
hasta ahora
[Música]
directo América la cita matinal de
France 24 en español de lunes a viernes
desde Bogotá con las noticias claves del
día en América Latina y el mundo y los
temas más importantes de la salud la
economía los deportes con invitados y
corresponsales
matinal directo a América en France 24 y
France 24.com
especial
Duelo titánico y competencia
futbolística fuera de serie
se enfrentan los mejores jugadores del
mundo
del 20 de noviembre al 18 de diciembre
sigan El Diario del mundial en francés
24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana de refi France
24 esta semana hablando de las posibles
salidas a la Guerra de Ucrania de un
eventual mesa de negociaciones Y de esa
visita de macron a biden para
resincronizar agendas que lo llaman lo
hacemos con eusebio vale Enric bonett
Yago del barrio y nuestro corresponsal
en Moscú sabía colas y hago qué
lecciones estamos aprendiendo de esta
crisis energética que vaya a sacar en
claro digamos la Europa posca ruso por
llamarlo de alguna forma vamos a sacar
en claro que no se puede depender a tan
alto nivel de una potencia como es Rusia
en la seguridad energética de un
continente o de cualquier país de la
Unión Europea siempre ha marcado que es
necesario que sea capaz de subsistir sin
el mayor proveedor pero estamos viendo
que
en muchos países de Europa del este no
era el caso Alemania depende muchísimo
delga ruso en Polonia otros países como
Hungría entonces lo que vamos a sacar
bien en claro es que las ideas que
estaban y los reglamentos que estaban
había que cumplirlos y que
recomendaciones muy necesarias para no
ser tan dependientes y en Francia ahora
no desde la parte del gas pero desde la
parte eléctrica es se ha sacado la
lección que hay que revisar de forma más
continua
los reactores porque los problemas de
corrosión que son los que se están dando
los circuitos de refrigeración son muy
difíciles de detectar pero es necesario
Tal vez un mejor mantenimiento o una
mejor programación del mantenimiento de
esos circuitos Europa sigue buscando
soluciones a la crisis política de
Ucrania pero también al futuro con la
energética les pregunto eusebio Enrique
saldrá reforzada por replantearse el
modelo como lo estoy diciendo yo hago o
debilitar a geopolíticamente si el
conflicto se extiende Cómo va a salir
Europa de todo esto
no es optimista yo veo muchas incógnitas
todavía para el futuro
estas negociaciones de las que
hablábamos es un futurible
Cómo va a quedar Rusia yo creo que este
es el también la gran pregunta no es
decir
una Rusia semi derrotada o que no ha
conseguido sus objetivos si colapsa este
sistema puede haber
Bielorrusia la situación es muy
inestable en el cáucaso es decir cómo va
a afrontar Europa una crisis una
implosión una posible implosión de Rusia
va mucho más allá del problema
energético es una crisis geopolítica
continental y
que es mucho más grave porque al fin al
cabo con Rusia vamos a tener que
entendernos el día de mañana Enrique y
siempre se dice que apu tiene que
dejarle al final una salida
sí
nuestro vecino No es la potencia de 150
millones de habitantes una potencia
nuclear y luego Es verdad que sí el
escenario de esta guerra es tan incierto
que es muy realmente muy complicado no
hacer cálculos detrás yo lo que sí que
observo es que desde el inicio de la
guerra el centro de gravedad en Europa
ha avanzado hacia el este Euro países
bálticos Polonia países donde detestan a
Rusia por su pasado soviético un odio
que es comprensivo antes de la es decir
lo mismo que baiden que sonaba las
alarmas cuando Francia Alemania y la
Europa del Oeste lo consideraban
exagerado No eso es un poco Exacto pero
luego yo creo que también la posición
que puede tener Francia Alemania España
también son posiciones de fondo
comprensibles claro tenemos pasados
distintos yo creo que habrá que llegar
un momento donde se equilibra la
posición en Europa que esos países del
este tampoco no se sientan
menospreciados porque Europa Tampoco
tampoco puede funcionar como una
pirámide donde Francia y Alemania manda
y el resto obedecen pero habrá que
quizás equilibrar esta posición y buscar
una posición de que interese como bloque
yo creo que también en el fondo la gran
cuestión de este conflicto será que
Europa se tiene que adaptar a una nueva
coyuntura mundial que es lo que se llama
la desglobalización no que probablemente
vamos a pasar una conversación abierta
donde el libro comercio pues
Lamento sentado a una co donde la
globalización va a quedar reducida más a
bloques más limitados y la valorización
sólo europea la verdad es que la Unión
Europea parece que le cuesta mucho más
adaptarse a este contexto que pues que
Rusia Bueno sobre todo que Estados
Unidos es china en gran parte porque en
el ADN en Europa está la cuestión del
libre cambio pero esta cuestión parece
que cada vez está quedando más desfasada
no y absolutamente Europa se celebrará
eso y en gran parte también para
afrontar el cambio climático porque el
libre cambio y cambio climático a menudo
son antagónicos y genera muchas
emisiones no Europa se tiene que adaptar
a este nuevo coyuntura mundial ahora
antes eusebio de la de esa situación de
inestabilidad que podría ser el
resultado de la implosión de lo que se
pueda pasar dentro de Rusia volvamos a
Moscú con savio para hablar de lo que
puede pasar dentro de Rusia porque en
los últimos días hemos visto a Putin
reuniéndose con madres de soldados
afines para intentar aplacar las
críticas mal preparados mal equipados lo
cual muestra una verdadera preocupación
interna Qué posibilidades Xavier hay de
que los familiares de soldados abran a
la derecha de oposición abierta se les
escucha se les da voz en alguna parte
Bueno yo creo que existe un riesgo de
eso porque hemos visto que ha sido
precisamente la movilización la que ha
causado más conmoción a los rusos desde
que ha empezado lo que Putin llama su
operación militar especial ni el inicio
de la guerra causó ese shock ni las
sanciones ni las restricciones de viaje
ni los problemas económicos que se están
viendo ahora lo que realmente sacudió a
los rusos es cuando empezaron a enviar a
sus hijos maridos primos amigos a la
guerra ahora mismo y en los próximos
meses van a ver volver a sus seres
queridos en ataúdes a Rusia eso yo estoy
convencido que causará una segunda
conmoción después de haberlos
marchar hacia el frente probablemente
quiere poner la venda antes de la herida
como decimos algunas veces
Yo creo que la herida va a ser demasiado
grande
Yago un sistema energético los
escenarios actuales muestran que un
sistema energético e Industrial neutro
en gases de efecto invernadero y
alimentado por hidrógeno es el sistema
energético del futuro qué retos hay
ahora para aproximarnos esa vía hombre
hay una cosa que no se habla mucho
cuando se habla de hidrógeno Y es que
hay que producirlo el hidrógeno no lo
tenemos en disposición seguimos siendo
dependientes lo mismo que nos ha pasado
pero para producir hidrógeno necesitamos
electricidad o necesitamos gas una de
las dos para que sea verde electricidad
entonces claro para poder llegar a un
escenario en el que dispongamos de
cantidades grandes de hidrógeno para
sustituirlo en la industria para quemar
o para sustituir algas en centrales de
como ciclo combinada de hidrógeno es
necesario una potencia instalada
renovable muchísimo mayor a la que
tenemos Entonces es verdad que esos
escenarios son posibles y hay
predicciones de la agencia Internacional
de la energía de la dirección general de
energía de la comisión europea pero para
llegar a esos escenarios primero es
necesario aumentar la potencia instalada
unos niveles
muy muy superiores a los existentes y al
ritmo actual Claro porque cuando les
hablamos de la situación energética de
Francia Hablamos de una de una gran
paradoja que es la energía nuclear que
en tiempos normales proporciona un 70%
de la electricidad que consume Francia
sin emitir gases de efecto invernadero y
ahora falla cuando más se le necesita no
es decir esa imagen de proyección de
potencia nuclear eusebio se encuentra
con esta gran paradoja ahora mismo es un
poco incomprensible la dejadez
el error de cálculo no sobre el
mantenimiento que se haya llegado esta
situación es en una empresa como edf un
gran monstruo es un fallo de
planificación planificación bastante
grave y mientras Putin con chantajes de
corte chantajes de uso de alarma nuclear
no sé si este tipo de comportamientos
denotan debilidad Enrique estas
actuaciones de Putin con el chantaje
permanente Sí cierto debilidad yo sobre
lo que muestra la gran debilidad de
Putin fue la como antes comentaba el
corresponsal muscular la movilización no
que fue la gran medida más más impopular
no luego estos amenazas de cortes pues
pueden demostrar cierta debilidad sobre
todo va a provocar lo más importante un
sufrimiento muy importante al pueblo
ucraniano a la población civil no que va
a pasar un invierno muy difícil y luego
y luego Es verdad que al mismo tiempo
muestran que a un Ruso tiene cierta
capacidad para bueno para para golpear
fuerte porque uranio actualmente dispone
de un sistema de defensa de aire
bastante potente después de haber
recibido mucho ayuda sobre todo de
Estados Unidos pero a pesar de eso los
bombardeos
dirigidos de Rusia están golpeando
sistemas de infraestructuras energéticas
y dejando a millones de personas sin sin
calefacción en pleno invierno y en parte
también ralentizando las posibles
ofensivas y movimientos militares
ucranianos volvamos a Moscú sabía el
chantaje nuclear al que nos referíamos
es el efecto de un Putin desesperado
Cómo se ve dentro de Rusia ese recurso
nuclear yo creo que este es un punto en
el que afortunadamente tenemos menos
experiencia porque no hemos vivido
conflictos
nucleares en los tiempos más más
recientes y alguna vez hablando con
expertos ellos me han trasladado que no
están muchísimo menos claro que el
armamento nuclear fuese útil en este
tipo de conflicto porque se podría
destruir una ciudad pero tal vez no un
ejército dado que están más dispersos y
para eso habría que tirar entonces
varias bombas además es un territorio
muy cercano
lo que sí que el kreming sabe muy bien
Es que
las armas nucleares siempre son una
buena amenaza tal vez no operativamente
pero sí como amenaza y da la sensación
de que el cráneo iba a tratar de usar
esa baza ante un accidente que como muy
bien sabe es todavía más refractario
que la sociedad rusa Así que es unas en
la manga que se puede usar sin
utilizarlo digamos pero me da la
sensación de que Estados Unidos también
tiene muy claro como lidiar con ese
fantasma y frente a ese as en la manga
les pregunto a mis compañeros
corresponsales está el comportamiento de
los medios es decir cuando los medios
hablamos de La amenaza nuclear es
complicado tomar el punto exacto no
exagerar no alarmar no convertirse en
amplificadores de los chantajes de Putin
pero al mismo tiempo no minimizar el
riesgo y exponer como hemos sido
traspasando líneas rojas porque también
lo hemos hecho estamos pecando más de un
lado que de otro eusebio cómo nos
situamos Cómo cómo ponemos el cursor los
medios antes esto creo que también sería
irresponsable no explicar la situación
es decir los arsenales están ahí la
doctrina militar rusa
prevé el uso de bombas nucleares
tácticas en un teatro de operaciones O
sea la doctrina rusa no solo
habla de disuasión como la francesa No
que los misiles franceses en teoría es
para evitar un conflicto para disuadir
al enemigo no según la doctrina rusa
vigente hoy se pueden utilizar armas de
pequeño de pequeña potencia entre
comillas nucleares para obtener una
ventaja decisiva en un conflicto
convencional en este caso Qué pasaría si
Ucrania amenaza con entrar en crimea es
decir
una un riesgo existe y no y sería
irresponsable no plantear esta situación
Enrique el comportamiento de los medios
entre el armar y contar las cosas
Completamente de acuerdo con el
compañero eusebi que no se puede
banalizar no el riesgo nuclear en ningún
caso no sería yo creo que sería el
escenario catastrófico de peor de los
escenarios sería una tercera guerra
mundial luego Es verdad que esta guerra
lo que nos ha mostrado es un poco la de
la disosión nuclear porque
históricamente se vendió Que las armas
nucleares en fondo en una herramienta de
paz porque impedían que las que los
bloques se hicieran la guerra entre
ellos y esto esta guerra ha demostrado
que no es del todo No es del todo cierto
porque es verdad que Estados Unidos nos
ha implicado directamente en la guerra
en gran parte por el riesgo de una
guerra nuclear pero sí que estamos casi
en una guerra casi directa entre bloques
Y dónde va a haber centenares de miles
de Muertos Bueno ya los hay pues y en el
fondo nos muestran los límites de las
armas nucleares yo creo que una de las
lecciones que se debería sacar de este
conflicto es que hay que desnuclearizar
el mundo y hay que reducir el armamento
nuclear a partir de ahora porque se ha
demostrado que las bombas atómicas no
sirven para construir la paz en el mundo
pues muchísimas gracias Aquí lo dejamos
no tengo tiempo para más Muchísimas
gracias eusebio Enrique Yago y a nuestro
corresponsal Xavier collares desde Moscú
y a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana en Primera Plana